hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled the benefit of using an
independent quality control
i'm susie valdez of labyrinth and i will
be your moderator for today's event
this educational web seminar is
sponsored by bio rad laboratories
i want to invite everyone to participate
by submitting your questions during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
and click send
any questions we do not have time for
during the webinar
will be captured and responded through
the q a list that will be posted next
week in the event resource
box which is located below the ask a
question box
you will also be able to download this
presentation handouts
from this event resource box starting on
october 30th
and if you have any trouble technically
or seeing or hearing
this presentation please contact us
through the ask us question box
and we will address those issues as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free pace
continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab
in the top right corner of the
presentation window
and follow the instructions to obtain
those credits
so let's get started i now present
today's speaker
mr abubakar yagupt mr abubakar yogurt is
the biochemistry supervisor at the
national guard health affairs
which is the large health care system in
saudi arabia
with over 3 500 hospital beds and
three million outpatient visits every
year
mr yangood trained as a medical
technologist in ontario canada and
continued
his work there for 10 years before
moving to saudi arabia
and taking a position with the quality
assurance and quality improvement
office of king basal specialist hospital
and research center
in addition to these rules mr obama
backer
is certified inspector for the college
of american pathology
or cap these combined experiences
make mr yagut well qualified to talk to
us today
about the value of independent quality
control
for complete biography of him please
visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen
welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
thank you thank you susie thank you for
this uh
kind introduction actually the pleasure
is mine
to be able to participate in this kind
of
seminar related to all kind of
quality related issues and thank you for
giving me the
opportunity to share with you
our uh laboratories findings and
troubleshooting
and like i said this is going to be for
the next 40 minutes you're going to
spend
some time in our laboratory since uh
it's not just going to be a presentation
it's actually going to be an invitation
for all the audience to come
and share with us our investigation
uh that's said i would
like to start the presentation um
the heading is that you can see it's
just the benefit of using an independent
quality control and those are case
studies
um and that's what it is uh we are going
to
see a lot of uh prints uh
screenshots uh quality reports
let's disconsider this you're gonna
spend another 40 minutes
in our laboratory so we're going to show
you everything it's not going to be like
where you can say if one control was out
what you do but in this case we're going
to show you this slot number this
reagent that this day
it was out but it was in and what
happened so it's like
just coming to our lab and seeing all
our
records um there's no financial conflict
to the scrolls here
we work with all the companies and we're
just going to show you our print house
okay learning objectives is going to be
by the end of this presentation
people will identify at least two
benefits
independent qc can provide when
troubleshooting
and out-of-control events they will also
be able to recognize at least
two advantages an inter-laboratory
comparison program can provide
most of our work is going to be about it
third party control independent control
what how it helped us and how we were
helped by
comparing our result to our peers that
is the main thing of all that case
studies that we're going to show you
today we're going to talk about four
examples we have a lot of them but for
the time
and we can explain it in details we're
going to talk about four
one of them is uh gamma gt ggt
we're going to talk about vancomycin
we're going to talk about micro albumin
and another case that is about
three b3
i was told that the my pointer doesn't
work so just to make it easy i have a
lot of
red rectangles and a lot of red circles
to show you
like exactly where to look uh because uh
we cannot just narrow down this is a
case study i have to show you the whole
report
but then i'm gonna show you where you
can see
which one which one i'm talking about so
just
to make sure here that you follow me
when i tell you my control was out or my
control was in
i just want to share with you and our
report at the end of the month we get a
qc net monthly report
there's a lot of them there's many
different independent but
it just happened that we used viral so
this is what my report is going to look
like
very simple anybody you can not even
with the experience with quality all
you're going to see here is you have the
white area
light green area and the dark green area
and then the vertical line is just
showing your standard
deviation index and
what it's going to show you is your bias
that's why it's from 2
up to -2 so you're either on a positive
side or
a negative bias um
the cvr coefficient variation ratio is
going to show how precise you are
and your laboratory is going to be
represented with a dot
so the dot is in the white area is good
and the dot is outside the whole
rectangle it is not good
so with that explain this is just uh
formulas
um you can look it up so we're not going
to discuss formulas we can
start the first slide of our
presentation
this is the gamma gt and again this is a
print out from
qcnid and all you have to look at that
red
rectangle on the bottom with the two red
circles the one
is for level one on the left red circle
and on the right red circle is for level
two and you can see the dot
we say the white area is good the light
green and then the dark green so the dot
is we can see it on the red circles it's
way on top
and at the end it's almost out anything
outside there
is going to be you're out of your peer
comparison
you can see also here this is the
laboratory comparison compared to your
other peers uh the other tear group
again you can you
just have to look at the red rectangle
area because the next one underneath is
glucose
iga you can see the dots right in the
middle but when it comes to the
red rectangle area for the gamma gt
you can see that on the left side the
two green circles level one and level
two for the chemistry assay and then you
can see them on the blue circles
in the middle where they are on the
outside
again you have the three rectangles
red on the right hand side that's just
to show you with the report that gives
you your laboratory
for this mass how you've been performing
what was your sd what was your cd
and it also gives you cumulative since
you start that
number how you've been performing next
to it it will show you how your peer
group is performing
and next to it is showing you how the
method group is being performing
so you're being compared to all these
people and you're sending we run our
control three times a day
imagine three times a day you're sending
your controls in being compared to all
your peers
uh okay so that is this
is one report of course the monthly
import is a very long report and i just
got one slide from each the monthly bias
you can see here the red rectangle again
at the bottom that's for the gamma gt
is run straight line as continuously on
a positive bias
the next slide will make it a little bit
easier see the red rectangle again at
the bottom for the gamma gt
continuously going on the positive bias
each
dot is one month every month every
report party was showing that we're
going
on a positive device just one not though
here it hasn't crossed the line above
it's not outside where it's not
acceptable it's just on the borderline
and you can see this continue this thing
by the way went for about over
two years um every month we've been
investigating
um we've been calling other hospitals
what's going on
if i have to talk to you about all the
investigation that we did throughout
the two years we'll take another
presentation so
we were investigating but then you you
will see what the reason was
now there are two questions here what
happened
and one question one presentation it
came which i'll tell you what happened
but one presentation and one of the
presentation the question came up that
is why we did not establish our own
range
this is going for about two years you
went through so many different reagent
law numbers different
numbers of controls your machine had
prevented maintenance
maybe twice or three times on that
period so why don't just
and that's how your machine is running
so why don't you just go and establish
your range and um
you don't have to look that you're your
own positive advice and that was one of
the questions but the answer is like
what this means what you can see here
this is a report from the european group
that about 100 laps around the world
they're telling you no we're using the
same lot number region same instruments
same lot number quality control and
we're all the same you're the only one
on a different side
so what's the point of establishing your
own brain it's just you're hiding the
problem
and that's why it took us a little bit
longer
and you know that's our problems but
um at least we did not give up we did
not think this was
okay we knew every month we thought it
was something going on and we need to
find out
if we had gone outside the limit and the
report says warning then we would have
we were going to stop
the assay and look for something else
now we're going to show you about what
happened and you're probably wondering
all this for two years
what happened is there was a product
information
that recommends that you adjust the
gamma gt calibration factor
using a standardized alignment solution
now you're talking about the uh
standard the calibration factor which
you need to multiply every result
with it and if you have a different
number then all your numbers
or your results would be different
we received this product information as
you can see here we received that on the
20th of november 2017
and if you look on the left side the red
rectangle next to it it says the death
issue
was september 19 2014.
it was like about three years we
for some time of course you haven't
received the reagent yet and then you
start
receiving the agent and that's about two
years and a half that took us
now here is the problem here is you have
let's say someone came from
a vacation they were deleting their
emails they did not send you the product
information
whatever the question is do you have a
checkpoint
in your laboratory where you can find
out if there is any problem like this
it could be this one it could be
anything there's many problems
at least in this case a third-party
controller independent
control and comparing to your peer
at least if you don't receive this thing
or if you have any problem
there are a lot of labs around the world
that you've been comparing with them
throughout every month they don't have
the same problem so they're going to
show you that no they're
you will find out that they're working
different than yours and that's where
you find out how you're doing and you
start investigating
so although we did not have this product
information but
we had a checkpoint which was the third
party control
and the peer comparison
now to know the disadvantage of not
having
a means of comparing your qc results
with your peer group example at unity or
any other company's
software if you have look at our
instrument printout before changing the
factor
it looks okay and then because if you're
comparing yourself to yourself then
you're not going to find out if there's
a problem
i'll show you the next slide and it's
going to show you that after we change
the factor
it looks okay so if you don't have any
comparison this is where you will look
now i'm going to put the two the two two
graphs together for you where
the first one ended and the second one
started when we changed the factor
and that is this is what you will see
see that red circle here where the
vertical
blue line is where we change the factor
and you can see that factor was changed
on december
26 2017
and we found out you can see the two red
rectangles inside the red circle that
one was the first the results before the
blue line was 67
and immediately after change the factor
run the same control that was sitting on
the bench and it gave
57 that's about 18 percent difference
so we were right at the 18 false
elevated
results and that reading
that was showing which explains the
years of continuous positive advice for
qc as well as for
patient results we did not give up we
did not establish the range and this is
what we're saying yes
uh some questions some investigation
might take you a day or two days or even
longer i mean
this thing took years but at least now
you know
you you can fix it now
that this problem is solved and
everybody's happy
everybody in the lab was happy and
everybody can go home but
as there any further action you want to
do and this case is like i said before
that blue line
this you were running on a 18 positive
if you did not have a 35 people
or if you didn't know then you were
compared to your peers and you know you
were even going higher
you might have been harming patient so
whenever you do you solve your problem
this is a good practice to go back a
little bit and see what happened to the
patients
uh in our case no patient harm was done
like i said
on the bottom rectangle here where you
can see we were just on the border line
but we did not cross the acceptable
limit so that means there were people
around that
area i give or taken every month so we
were okay
but for a laboratory and you see the top
left rectangle here where we participate
also in westgard sigma verification
program
with cap and everything and for a lab
that is performing at five sigma six
sigma to see one analyte going like this
we knew there was a problem
and it wasn't acceptable by our
standards and that's why we continuously
investigate it
now if this if we did not have the third
particle if we if we didn't have
people telling us our peer group telling
us that are you running on a
positive bias maybe that was in our case
we were like it was 18 it could be 20 25
to the point where you can hire a
patient
what would be the magnitude of the risk
if there was no appear comparison
the direct effect of all that for the
patient would be that
we can see how on that period you can
see where it says number one
on the left green circle here on our
rectangle you will see
on that period where we have the gamma
gt problem we run about 329
342 samples of gamma gt as a number of
samples on that period
um you can calculate it and you can find
out the number of
patients how many from how many patients
that one can we we're actually lucky we
have the allen iq
the bis software which calculates uh
turnaround time and a lot of thing how
the instrument is performing among those
things it also calculates for you on
that period
uh number of patients number of patients
at uh samples number of samples per
patient
a patient per day and all the statistics
so this is where this
3.3 samples per patient came from so on
that period we were having
this 3 000 329 000 came from about
99 800 which i just rounded to 100
000 patients now you can see we were
talking about all this gamma bt was
going higher
if there was a problem when you were
harming patients you would have been
harming about 100 000
patients if your problem was one day you
could have your
population of one day if it's longer
you're going to harm a little bit
more patient to show you now just to see
what happened um um
you you have to if you have those
stations you have to call them and you
know
whatever you're gonna do but let's see
here
as a lab what do we do to avoid
a problem like this or how can we
protect or what can we learn
let's see the cost of good quality
versus the cost of poor quality which
means what do you invest
ahead of time or what you pay at
the problem solving later or a damage
control in our case and this is the real
data here we use one vial for three days
that quality control
it takes that three days to finish it so
it takes about
10 miles per month for 30 days a kit
comes with 12 vials that's about a
thousand solution this is an oil
price it could be like 1 500 i don't
know but
let's say a thousand and we use level
one and level two
so we're gonna use two kits per month
which is gonna make it
two thousand that period that we had a
problem with gamma gt
elsewhere as a three years that's 36
months
so we actually invested 72 000 saudi
wheels
which is about 19 200 us dollars
this is the real data if you again this
is like coming from the real lab where
if you have three instruments and you
run three times
control per day you will end up using
about
one kid per month so that's that's
nineteen thousand
but on the other hand if those if you
had harmed those hundred thousand
patients and they sue you and the court
let's say for example that they
are worth about a thousand saudi wheels
per patient which doesn't happen
um that's about three hundred dollars
you don't get harmed by a lab and go
sue and then you get three hundred
dollars but just for example
if we say those hundred you're going to
give 1 000 saudi reals for those 100 000
people or patients
that's a hundred million
which is which comes to 26 million us
dollars
now just trying to show you the
difference if you invest
up front and people don't look at it
this is just for one analyte
and 19 000 we use that control to
monitor about 32 analyze that we have
30 or 32 and if you harm
a patient from one analyte you can go up
to this much just to show you when you
when you spend
invest ahead of time into checkpoints
quality
to con contents of your instrumentation
it's a lot a lot cheaper than when you
have to do damage control
and this is what i mean by a cost of
good quality cost of poor quality but
if you really want to know about cost of
quality then you can actually
as a good topic you can go to clsi
reports
understanding the cost of quality in
laboratory
and uh because the cost of quality is a
lot of details and you're going to talk
about costs of quality for return of
investment
costs of quality prevention costs
appraisal costs upfront cost
costs of poor quality internal failure
hard costs of course all these details
you know and there's a lot of
uh templates forms charts to use when
you when you study about cost of quality
and so you can read it here always when
you have a report like this just look
for the updated one if you're gonna read
it i'm not sure
what the latest one but again on one
note here
the next webinar actually after this one
is going to be about cost of quality so
this
is an opportunity if you look and this
one attracts you to know how much is
going to see again you can you can
attend the next seminar you'll see you
learn a little bit about cost of quality
um after the problem so this is quickly
i'm going to go this is before
changing the factor on the left side and
you can see the red rectangle
on the bottom where the red arrow is
showing you that we were on the on
high end and then after changing the
factor
we have to wait and then print the
report for you so we can
attach it here and the blue arrow you
see we're back to the red
area which does have the improvement
and here this is uh laboratory
comparison compared to our peers on the
left side you can see the red arrow we
were out
and then here we are almost on the
average among the best of the peers
right
in the middle uh again
before and after with the imprecision
report you can see the red arrows on the
left side we were running continuously
and then the blue arrows everything
it went we're not a positive ass anymore
now when you hear something like this
you think oh how often this happened it
doesn't happen
to me or it doesn't happen to anybody
and just a lot of times we troubleshoot
we investigate and we don't keep record
we just let it go and then it happens a
year later and
we go through the same problem now
learning from
our mistakes and what are the chance of
this will happen to your life
or what are the chances that would
happen to us again
well let me share with you this one we
had our second wave of gamma gt a
positive bias
after two years and nine months on 29th
september that's like about a week or
two weeks ago
we were trying to do uh a dilution we
have to look so
look at the number one this is 29
september at 6 39 a.m the qc was like
this
and then you 59 and then you see the red
vertical line something happened
everything shifted up and then you see
the blue vertical line
the green vertical line something
happened and everything went
bad so what happened the next one when
you see
that this is the result after something
happened after the red line and it went
up
so the question is what happened
immediately right there
because we had the same issue everybody
in the lab said wait a minute maybe this
looks like the factor problem that we
had years ago
because people are documented and it was
they remember they learned from it
we didn't go looking for a reagent to
calibrate again
so what happened was in the morning
we had downloaded an assay file and when
you download the new one
always the default goes to non-ifcc
factor and that one changed
but we are so we took one day this is
the second day at 6 00 a.m
6 4 a.m control and then after that
we have called the company that they
before they came the next day and they
changed the factor to
ifcc factor which is the one for our
instrument
and immediately we run the control and
you can see it went back
now if you see from number two the first
result after the red vertical line was
at
uh 1 25 p.m 29
and then if you see the first
green result after the green line is on
the next day
at um 6
44 am um at 3 2 pm
that's a difference of 26 hours
and it's the same issue that took us
before about three years
at this time the problem was solved in
two days and not three years
that is just to show keep record um
share information with peer like this so
people don't have to repeat
the same mistakes and so on is just
learning from
uh why ifcc factor some people might say
what is ifcc pattern
um yes the factor
for the instrument the damage the insert
package i'll tell you it's highlighted
if you can see it cap the cd 2020 kit
instruction tells you you're an ifcc
product information and the two
screenshots in the bottom and the left
is the one when we calibrate it and you
can see that as the nine ifcc calibrator
that came down and we were getting the
wrong grid so the result
shifted up and then when we change it
you can see the different
value of the ifcc faster and that's
how we solve the problem now this case
has got a lot of things to learn from it
but
uh to summarize it is a monthly report
show and marginal performance
continuously on a positive advice for a
long time
but investigation showed that vendor
product information that
recommends adjust calibration factor
calibration was adjusted
problem solved and we unfortunately had
a second wave of gamma gt but
because of the record and learning from
previous experience we solve it
immediately within the same day in this
case it just showed you that
because we had we've been compared to
our peer that's how we found but if you
are going to go like this for years
you're just going to establish your
branch and continue and you
okay now we're going to talk about this
is the second case that i have
normally people uh they tell your
control was out and
whether it's your peer group or
something to tell you're out and you
investigate
this is a different scenarios from the
other side and i think a lot of people
in the lab are going to like it
in this case what we had on february
2018 pharmacy called and they said we
are giving them
you're giving us the higher results than
expected for a trough and
my c level so we looked up
checked our results on instruments we
checked our qc results in pc history on
unity
how it's been performing saying that
something happened before and we didn't
office it
we checked cap samples surveys
everything was okay
and our controls are good compared to
peers so we call the pharmacy and we
told them
look this is the problem we don't have
anything it looks everything is okay
see if there is anything on your side
maybe there's a mix-up
samples whatever but the problem has
gone for about three months at that time
now i'm going to show you this is in our
lab this is our unity
two instrument performance with quality
control material
and this is compared to peer group 75
labs and
method of 122 labs our result compared
to them was right in the middle you can
see the red rectangle
and the two of them those are two
instruments and if you can see inside
the red rectangle level one level two
level three
the dot is where we sound compared to
our pure group and right in the white
area in the middle
so with quality control we're performing
very good
that means if those samples that the
pharmacy are complaining about they have
gone to any of those 75 labs around the
world
they would have got the same result so
hopefully we are performing we don't
have a problem it's just to
show you that you don't go crazy and
recalibrate and try to find out
a less result to compare to it but it's
just
giving you confidence now the question
is if the instrument is performing like
this with quality contour
is there any chance that it will perform
differently with patient
that would patient all of a sudden it
would give us a high result
and and with the control is good let's
see
this is the result of two instruments
with a patient
sample in the past two years i'm just
going to explain what the graph is
this is a total number of vancomycin
critical results
they found for the physician like every
lab you have like
your troponin or your potassium and
result is uh critical
i flags the red your system and your way
you call and then you
read back with the physician and then
you put the comment in the system and
then you release it on the system
so this is among our lists and every lab
have their own list vancomycin happened
to be in one of our lists so
we had this data to go back and look so
we went back from january 17
all the way to september 18. of course
it didn't start like this i just did
three months to see
what the pharmacy is talking about and
then when we look the picture like
looks like this i was scared away and i
continued backward to
january 2017 which means
is you see those numbers age how many
critical results we call per month and
the red
line before the green vertical line is
before
where something happened and then after
so you can see we're on average about 65
70 back home mice in critical results
high critical results per month so we
were bus all of a sudden around that
green
vertical line something happened we
start reporting
an average of uh 85 90
per month and it stayed the same so
definitely there is a problem
um with the patient we look with the
quality control the instruments were
parking perfect
you look with this here you can see this
picture something happened
right november 2017 and you can see that
the blue
arrow is on february 18th that's when we
received the call
and then we didn't go crazy looking to
try to solve the problem we call the
pharmacy no and we gave them about
just about two months before this green
line and two months after to show them
there's a difference
they discuss in their meeting and we
found out when they called
that i'm going to show you now what what
happened
i'm going to show you what happened but
why this example always when you have a
third-party control
to being compared to other people
everybody's working the same and you
look okay
don't look when you receive a complaint
it could be a nurse that makes
examples there's something a pre and
post they were mixing
don't go crazy and investigate that
unless you have a real
reason investigate but just make sure
that you know you're also okay
um but what happened is i'm going to
show you the problem was pre-analytical
but
here it says up to 75 of lab error
occurs in pre-analytical phase
um we hear that a lot i don't have where
the source it came from but what is
pre-analytical most of the times in the
lab when we hear pre-analytical we think
or the centrifuge it wasn't centrifuged
good or maybe the
the porter took time to bring the sample
from the collection area
and that's how the patient did not fast
that's pretty analytical or you know go
all the way to the patient you go
pre-create free analytical
but nobody would go any further let's
show you this example
was pharmacy investigator they looked
and then they found there was a memo
on january 18 and they called us on
february
that says there was an urgent recall for
the replace the vancomycin
and concerns were raised from clinical
pharmacists regarding an alarming
increase in the vancomycin trough
results
there was a problem with the medication
so that graph that i showed you were
before that green that green line is
when
we start using the medication on the
patient and everything before that was a
different
number of medication everything after so
just to show you the data that
laboratories has this
kind of data this kind of graph would
not be presented by the family
by the pharmacy and it cannot be
presented by the manufacturing company
that manufactured
the medication it's the lab that shows
you uh things like
this a lot of data in the lab and
now that we with a lot of softwares that
we have we can even present a lot
more we can benefit from all the data
that we have
so to summarize that one pharmacy called
and they say they're having
higher than expected result from
ventromycin unity reports showed the
performance good performance we gave us
the confidence
to not to go crazy and to discuss with
the pharmacy uh no further investigation
analytical phase an original problem was
found to be pre-pre-analytical which was
the medication
i don't know i i could pre-pre just to
show you how far you can go with the
pre-analytical it's not just the
centrifuge
not just the report or not just the
patient it can go free free all the way
to anything can happen the lab results
if you have an independent control
with uh compared to other peers then you
know
whether you're doing good or bad if
you're okay or not
we're gonna go to uh a third case that's
a
micro argument urine argument this is
this is almost as okay like in every
lapse
and 19 february 2019 unity real time
our monthly evaluation report shows
you're in chemistry lot number that
expires on this
again like i said this is case studies
we're not just giving an example if you
have this slot number that expires
in this time on february 19 2009 you can
go back and see how your results was
so this is a real case and what happened
to level of control
outside the acceptable peer group
compared to six million laboratories
globally and after
combining 2434 points
and after all these two for you if you
are out that means there is a problem
with you all these people are telling
you no you're not performing like
us and that was for two instruments we
have two instruments so uh definitely
there is a problem
immediately and now if you can see we
looked at the unity report this is what
we got this is what alarm does
working and then you see that the first
red
circle on the left that's what it's
telling you you can see the dot is way
out and there's a little arrow above it
that's out
that's not like the gamma gt what it
used to be just at the border
this one is way out so now you have a
problem
and the report monthly evaluation report
is telling you on the
right hand side the red circle is
telling you warning
now all these labs are telling you you
know what you are performing without
your harming patient you immediately
have to stop in this case and solve the
problem that you cannot continue
and this one it can be like any
anything in the lab i said there was if
you can see the uh
the scan at the bottom which says
calibration the micro albumin assay must
be calibrated using a micro argument
calibrator
with the 0 3 supplied separately
what we had was the one in our fridge we
had the one that's at the end
zero two and now it wants to be
calibrated with zero
three that ends with zero three
calibrator
um etc supplies separately now there's
two cases either we have the previous
calibrators and we did not get rid of
them when the new calibrators came all
the suppliers they had the lot number
from before nobody noticed and they send
it to us we put it
on in our fridge
things like this you don't catch it
because calibrator is good and
everything is okay
unless you have let's see in some of
them they come with that pink uh
north is where it tells you wait a
minute this cannot be calibrated
maybe worcester maybe was thrown but we
don't know but at least the ones we have
it didn't have this notice so there's no
way you can find out
if i think of that when you have a peer
group comparison you can find out if you
hope there was a problem so you can see
that the gamma gt was a
different problem this one is different
and all the ball being caught by an
independent control and a peer
comparison
now the main thing with this example
is to show you this is this is a
printout from
our instrument you see that the line
where it says
uh calibrated here after the calibration
it went down
and that was the problem solved but the
main thing here is not like changing
calibrator and solve the problem the
main thing is you look at the red
rectangle on the bottom and it tells you
on february 19 at 3
40 p.m on february 19 at 3 40 pm we
solved the problem and we went home
now if you know if you participate in
cab or unity
after the result is online a day or two
days later they tell they send you an
email saying your results is online and
a lot of people they're busy
but once you see this uh emails then you
start looking at it
download it in our case
this is an email you can see the red
arrow that's
my name it came at 904 p.m on the same
day
and that that to show you why we're
using this example on the bottom now you
can say
email from biorad on february 19th at
9pm
which was going to be open on the next
day but investigation done and problems
solved for two
instruments at 3 40 pm so 3 40 we
finished we went home problem solved
and then at night we were notified
but that means how did the lab do that
unity report it comes on the 16th of
every month
we don't wait until the 17 or on the 18
that unity tell us your results online
same thing with cap as the minute our
result is online
rpi will send us an email say it's
online so that way
which which shows you this takes a lot
of dedicated people working
this i just showed this example to show
you there's a lot of people who have a
monthly checklist they wait for things
they don't
procrastinate things the
the minute they have the thing they
start working on it and uh
third-party control by itself is not
going to do you anything
um pure comparison is not going to be
unless you have the real people who are
waiting
in the lab and understand and
proactively try to solve
the problems that when this one he saved
about two days like uh
24 hours it's better if i had come in
the hospital at night i would be very
happy that the problem was solved
when my samples were sent to the lord as
opposed to the love or sleeping they
fixed the problem the next day
so this is an easy example it's a factor
problem it's a calibrator problem
but just to show you how it was cut
ahead of time and solved immediately
i am assuming a lot of times people say
invest on good people and
we do have a lot of good people here now
unity report for january this is the
summary for that was the two controls
for the two instruments outside the peer
group
we said investigation as per reagent
insert package we found out a
need different version of calibrator
than the one in use
calibrated problem solved the minute we
printed this one actually the three
people i went to look for the history of
the problems pc
it our qi went to look at uh unity
daily what happened our senior from the
after the bench we wanted the fridge to
look at the calibrators and the insert
package
and everybody stopped working it's it
looks easy now on slides but there's a
lot of
work went into it to solve this problem
also
now we're going to show you the last
case this is about
free t3 for people who are aware about
the
six point calibrator uh product
information was received on september
that we were going to receive a new
reagent
a new assay file that needs a new asset
file of course a new calibrator and this
time the calibrator is going to be a six
point calibrator before that
all the time the uh free t3 was being
calibrated by two point calibrator
so we waited and we finished our reagent
what we have and
once we came to the new reagent you
start a machine you download the new
answer you love the new reagent
all the steps that you know and then you
run your control
immediately after starting the new
calibrator buyer at qc results were low
outside the manufacture range for two
different lot numbers at that time we
were going to switch from one lot number
to another
so we were validating the next control
and
we tried the two of them they were out
the
two lots of independent control picked
up the problem sure there was a problem
uh singer we asked the company to give
us a single
accompanying control all levels on the
low side but within
the range um and they were on the low
side but within the range
if i am in the lab and i'm using them i
would have accepted patient results
and it was it wasn't out to the point
where you can say
very low no it was it was in but on the
low side you notice on the lowest edges
you know
the two independent controls lot numbers
are going very low so that's what
allowed otherwise it was within except
brain
we would have run patient the
manufacture control so did not pick up
the problem we can say that but
we ran the previous caps survey we had
the one we had was cb 2019 we ran in
again
one sample was out and the resp3 samples
were on a negative bias
some people might argue here that some
analytes are not stable
and some are other so this is not a good
judgment but when you have two
independent control are way out
and one controller is in we we thought
there was a problem and we asked for
investigation and we called
our partner to give us a different lot
number of calibrator
this is what it shows you this is we
were going like this
continuously was going until you see
that arrow below the red
the red circle that result is right
first time it went down that's after the
calibration
and you can see after that it stays like
that and you can if you have this
problem you can
look at it it means say lot number
calibrator and everything like i said
space
study you can you can relate to it you
can go back actually and you can see if
you were having this problem
um if you were having this problem and
only a lot of times in the lab they said
oh we had some problem for a while and
then it sold by itself well maybe that
calibrator finished and then when you
get the calculator that we have your
problem will be fixed
but the thing is if you have a third
party control you can catch the problem
early
so what we did two controls out uh
company control that we thought it was
going to be
okay in the middle range on the average
it was
even running low so we immediately
stopped the assay for free d3 until a
correct
calibration from outside the rights
and this as you can see here that we
disable it why this example
a lower laboratories they're afraid to
stop the assets they're all
you know that's not easy people to stop
but don't be afraid
if you get to the point where you don't
think you're giving the correct result
it's better no result than
wrong result don't be afraid to stop of
course you're not going to stop by
yourself
you're going to discuss with this
section head and everybody's going to be
involved
but at least is an option that
is until you solve your problem
recalibrate using the newly arrived
calibrator and
actually because we were told this we
were the only hospital that we were we
only love that we were complaining about
it and nobody else complained
and then we found other another
calibrator private
some labs in europe had the same problem
they complained about it and there was a
new calibrator that was made and it came
so this is course the new
single the company control slot number
you can see went up
after that red line on the left side
you can see it went up on the right side
as the biowrap controls
were using see it went up also so the
problem was solved within the
exceptional range and we resume
patient testing
just to summarize that once six point
calibrators started
two lot numbers of uh viral outside
range
independent qc picked up the problem a
company qc was low but
within the range uh cap proficiency
testing was
out and the main thing here is as you
know
whether the company control was out or
this one as we felt that there is a
problem
and we knew there was a little bit of
running outside the acceptable limit low
so the main thing in this in this
example is that stop the assay
and then and you calibrate the revival
the problem was solved with the new
calibrator
uh take home message is for the medical
technologies a lot of people in the lab
you have a problem you hear someone is
telling you just establish range
or application specialist where tommy
doesn't know what the problem is or
establishment well my advice to take
home message would be in every
calculate or re-establish qc range
unless there is a very good
justification when it's due
we all know when you establish range and
what happened and
how long we are it's everybody knows
that but don't go ahead
and resort to that solution before you
do
other investigation companies educate
client about your product
a lot of people have unity a lot of
people have third party a lot of people
have
software's from companies and don't know
how to use it so a lot of
companies should i think to my opinion i
should push and come and visit the labs
and tell people
look we have this let me teach you how
to use it
for laboratories i strongly agree with
this ones
use independent control establish your
own pc range and participate in monthly
qc year comparison
and for national guard for our team here
i'd like to thank the staff for
all that other work that they're doing
with that said i think i'm on my last
slide
i'd like to thank everybody for
listening
and if there's any questions well i'm
happy to answer them
and thank you oma for that great
presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar and if you have any questions
you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box
located on the left of your screen
so let's get started for this webinar is
also
a short survey available to collect some
feedback and you can submit those
answers there any time during the q a
so our first question is for the ggt
example you showed us the test was
performing at a higher
bias for a while did the proficiency
test
pick up on this
yes yes the proficiency test
was picking up and it was actually it
was giving exactly the same
picture as the third party control was
given
like you said under an example where it
was just
uh close to the past two
standard innovation bias but it wasn't
out the same with the fab reports every
time we ran up it was on the on the
higher side but it was in
so you know it's exactly that uh what
what is the
cap they're sending samples no
concentration they're comparing you to
your peer group
same instruments same reagent that
they're using and the
independent control is the same where
they you get this known concentration
and you send results to the company and
they're comparing it to your peer
so if everything is okay they should
perform the same so
known samples that were given for us and
the result went to cap
it showed we are on the positive side
compared to here and the bi-rad control
at the end of the month we're showing
the same picture it's just
all the other investigation would be
running recalibrated
there was a one thing calibration factor
that was missed
so yes if you are working good if you're
the with the third party controller
cab should have the same picture to show
you the same picture and it did
we have a capital c uh 2017
it looks exactly like the bio-rad report
that you were seeing
and the cap 2018 looks right in the
middle
so yes it did pick it up
thank you so much abba walker and i want
to thank our audience members
for these great questions coming in our
next
question from an audience remember says
can i use my calibrator material to
test my performance
wow this looks like a lot of people
right from the lab there's
a lot of practical questions people
if the question is do i use my
calibrator
as a control i would have to say i
strongly advise against it
but since this is a case study about
practical laboratory and a practical lab
if you just calibrated your instrument
and you want to run
control and you don't have anything what
do you do i cannot give you the answer
and say no
and leave it at that if you really
really have to use if you don't have a
control you don't have a third-party
controller you don't want to have an
uh company control you don't have a
pulled sample that uses the control you
all of a sudden you just walk up and you
find yourself you don't have control and
you have to use
a calibrator as a control please please
use a different lot number
of calibrator as a controller calibrate
with one lot number
and then use another lot number of
calibrator to run the control because
what is a calibrator let's say it's a
six point calibrator you will have a
virus
a b c d and then it will give you a
non-concentration the machine is going
to read them and then it's going to make
a line
so and actually what the machine did was
it just read the concentration of those
vials
and now two minutes later once it did
and draw the line for you you're going
to give it this let's say you decided to
run
file number two or number six as a
control so you're gonna run them don't
bother running them because you just run
them like two minutes of what they give
you the reading
so if you really have the priority would
be if you have a third-party controller
that's fine
if not use the company control if not
try
to use the uh in-house control also like
if you can
save and a sample that you can run it
all the time
so the answer if you are going to use
calibrator please as a control piece
make sure
you use a different lot now
thank you so much yes and how often
would you recommend to run
the qc
well it's all about practical a lot of
people that are asking these questions
um running how often you run the
quality control um there's a lot of
software that will tell you to go to
westgard advisory but
this thing they will tell you if you are
running if your range is a one sd
rule then you can run it twice a day if
you are touristy you can run this you
can do this a lot of things you can go
back
and people depends on who is using and
how comfortable you are and what
analytes you use mainly
um a lot of times we go to seminars and
presentation like this and we ask those
questions and people will answer they
say okay
this range use it twice if that is
enough and then we go back to the lab
and the next day is business as usual
and then a month later you ask me and
then they will say oh yeah we've been
using it three times a day
before and we still using it so just to
give you
an advice just from a practical point
you run your control at eight o'clock in
the morning and then you run it at
uh four p.m and then you run it at let's
say
12 midnight if the eight o'clock is
control is okay
and then your 4 p.m is bad then you
don't know if that went
out at 359 or it went to 801. so you're
going to look at all the samples in
between
rule of thumb is what do you want to do
do you want to go back
eight hours and see like let's say about
a hundred patient if you run a hundred
or you want to run the control once a
day and then when there's a problem you
go about 24 hours
so it just depends on you because you
are
once it goes out you are going to do a
troubleshooting you will go back
so how many patients and how much longer
do you want to go back just
look at it that way and how often you
have a problem
okay thank you
we have time for a couple of more
questions here's another great question
when the manufacturer says i have to run
the in-kit control should i still run an
independent control
a simple answer is yes because the
simple control
you're gonna run it other people are
gonna you're gonna be compared to
everybody because at that kid control if
the kit was
stayed outside or it was not the right
temperature
you not know so a lot of assays the
companies tell you
you have to run their controls to
validate the calibration
run it if the company says yes you can
run it but it doesn't have to
add an independent control by then you
are comparing you're finding out how you
did
compared to other people who are using
the same kit and same control
so yes actually i advise to add
one more control or two
thank you so much our walker this has
been so great we have time for one more
question
is independent qc mandatory
well um i would love to see it mandatory
you've seen now four cases example how
we solve the problem
and i was in the problem of the lab that
was told that you say
patient you say wrong results
um i always tell people that now a lot
of people are tab accredited
and imagine you have a lot that's doing
all this work they're running uh
an independent control they're doing
that daily and they're sending it
outside and being compared to
their peers three times a day
and there's a lot that just run either
third party control are not compared to
peers or they're just running that
company control
i don't know which lab would you rather
go for your blood test
this one is being compared three times
now what top does is
cup sends you twice a year or three
times a year five samples five samples
here after three months five samples and
the end of the year five so those are 15
samples they take a screenshot of how
you're doing
mainly now how can you go wrong
when when the quality control
independent control if you're running
you'll be compared you'll send your
result
and if you find your control three times
so
you're like having cab three times a day
which is a lot better than having
some your samples being compared to your
peers three times a year imagine three
times a day
so i think in the future it looks like
it's going to be
mandatory i know that iso15189
um says they should be considered even
if you are running the company control
and i'm sure a cab is going to catch up
and
you can see a lot the more examples like
this come the more people want to raise
the bar
i think i'm the first people that i'll
tell you yes it should be mandatory
thank you so much for your time today
and before we go
i want to thank our audience members for
joining us today as well and for their
interesting questions and questions we
did not have time for today
will be answered and posted in the event
resources by the end of next week and
this webcast can be available
for on-demand in the auditorium from
friday on
if you found it informative and helpful
please share it with your colleagues
bio-rad will be hosting a new qc related
webinar
every month this year and next month's
topic
is cost of quality and the medical
laboratory 2020
and it will be held on november 18th
please check back
regularly for new topics and remember to
take a look at the boost in the exhibit
hall
of the virtual conference until next
time
take care stay healthy and bye bye
thank you again sir thank you